I MISSED MY BATWOMAN, SUZANNE,
AND MY BAT-SON...
BAT-EVERYTHING.
HEY, THE BIKE LANES
ARE CLEARLY MARKED.
- [bleep] YOU, BATMAN!
- [bleep] YOU.
[bleep].
BUT I DID MY BEST
TO FIND CRIMINAL MASTERMINDS
OR AS CLOSE
AS I COULD COME.
EXCUSE ME.
THIS SHOPPING CART
DOES NOT BELONG TO YOU.
I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE FOOD SAVER.
- WHAT?
- I'M BATMAN.
IT WAS CLEAR TO ME
THAT THE IDEA
OF A PRIVATE CITIZEN
FIGHTING CRIME
IS OF NO VALUE WHATSOEVER.
THAT SHOULD BE LEFT
TO POLICE OFFICERS
WITH THE PROPER TRAINING,
EQUIPMENT,
AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO SOCIETY.
HOW THIS NEVER OCCURRED
TO BATMAN IS BEYOND ME.
YOO-HOO.
YOU'RE BREAKING THE LAW
RIGHT NOW.
YOU MIND COMING WITH ME
TO THE POLICE STATION?
- HA HA.
IT'S BATMAN.
- STOP--OW.
THAT'S DISGUSTING.
WHAT'S THE MATTER WITH YOU?
[cell phone rings]
- WHAT?
- CONTROL YOURSELF.
HELLO?
- WHERE ARE YOU?
WE'RE AT THE COURTHOUSE.
- WHAT?
NO.
- I DON'T KNOW--
- NO, NO, NO, NO.
NO, THAT WAS TOMORROW.
OH, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO.
I'M HERE.
I JUST GOT HERE.
WHAT FLOOR
ARE YOU GUYS ON?
OKAY.
WELL, WHICH WAY IS IT?
WHICH WAY DO YOU GO IN
ONCE YOU'RE UP TOP,
ONCE YOU'RE AT THE BEGINNING?
OH.
OH, YOU CAME IN
THROUGH THE PARKING GARAGE?
WELL, WHEN YOU'RE IN THE LOBBY,
IS IT ALL
ONE LOBBY FOR EVERYTHING,
OR IS IT...?
IF YOU'RE STANDING
ON THE SIDEWALK--HANG ON.
HEY, YOU GUYS, DO YOU KNOW
WHERE FAMILY COURT IS?
WHAT FL--OR WHICH ENTRANCE
YOU GO IN FOR FAMILY COURT?
IS IT THE MIDDLE?
OKAY, THANK YOU.
YEAH, I GOT IT.
I'M GOING IN THE MIDDLE DOOR.
[elevator beeping]
- FORREST?
- YES.
SUZANNE, CAN I SPEAK WITH YOU
FOR JUST ONE SECOND, PLEASE?
JUST ONE SECOND, PLEASE.
- WHY ARE YOU DRESSED
LIKE THIS?
ARE YOU GOING CRAZY?
- NO.
LET'S NOT DO THIS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE DIVORCED.
LET'S JUST GO--
- OKAY, FORREST,
I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU ARE NOT
IN THE BEST FRAME OF MIND
RIGHT NOW, OKAY?
- I AM THINKING VERY CLEARLY.
- YOU ARE CLEARLY NOT.
BUT I AM CERTAIN
THAT THIS IS BEST FOR US, OKAY?
- HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT?
WE HAVE A LIFE TOGETHER.
- I CAN'T--
- MACNEIL!
- [sighs]
- SUZANNE--SUZANNE.
- STOP IT.
I'M SORRY.
- IT'S ALL RIGHT.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
- THIS WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE WEDNESDAY.
- I WAS LOOKING
AT LAST YEAR'S CALENDAR.
- [sighing]